Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
They're currently working
on Ahsoka Season 2
and right now, the Thrawn movie.
Most of what's happening right now
just in general, with all the different
shows that are crossing over
in this part of the timeline,
like The Mandalorian,
the upcoming stuff like Skeleton Crew
are all adapting that original Thrawn
trilogy of books.
one of the biggest characters that a lot
of you have been asking you about that
we haven't seen very obviously on screen
yet is Mara Jade.
So I'll explain
what's going on with the character
in Some of you actually realize this,
but Dave Filoni has actually already
introduced a version of her
that most people haven't spotted it yet.
we'll explain what's going on, how
this is going to plot through season two,
what's going on with Luke Skywalker,
the Mandalorian grogu you.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
The Ahsoka finale is happening next.
We're doing a giveaway
for the Mandalorian Blu ray.
All you have to do to enter
is being subscriber
and let me know what you want to see
during Ahsoka Season two.
Careful for spoilers for everything on
the show so far if you're not caught up.
But the RJ character up to this point
is probably one of the biggest people
that most people haven't noticed
in the newer live action stuff.
most longtime fans will affectionately
know her as Luke Skywalker's wife.
That's right.
Luke Skywalker did have a wife and son
in the Legends material.
the fact that she is a legends character
in present day is one of the main reasons
why younger fans don't have any idea who
she is or what happened to Luke Skywalker
after Return of the Jedi
before Disney bought Star Wars.
So rewind to October 2012.
Disney buys Star Wars.
What happens is
there's years and years of story
that have been created to fill the holes
between the Star Wars original trilogy,
the prequel movies
to explain
what happened to all the characters,
like all the way back to Knights
of the Old Republic in present day.
What happened
after the events of Return of the Jedi?
that was the original Thrawn trilogy,
starting with Heir to the Empire.
Disney basically called all that stuff.
Legend said that it wasn't Canon anymore.
And the new material, the new books,
the new TV shows going forward after 2012
created underneath Disney's brand would be
the new Canon wound up happening, though
is that Dave Filoni got to the Star Wars
Rebels series in 2014.
He started re canonizing
all that legend stuff,
the biggest thing
being the Thrawn character.
he did
change some of his backstory
from the original Thrawn trilogy,
but largely started bringing back
all this legend stuff
but it really wasn't until he and Jon
Favreau started doing the live action
shows The Mandalorian season one,
that they really started to
recognize and adapt elements from that
Thrawn trilogy of books in the nineties.
Like it really started to feel like
they were doing the Thrawn trilogy
And for a lot of Star Wars
fans in the nineties
after the original trilogy had long
since come out for a long time.
Everyone just assumed that there
would never be any more Star Wars movies.
We didn't know that the prequels
were going to be a thing yet,
so for all the fans.
Back then, the Thrawn trilogy was like
our sequel trilogy and it's amazing
if you haven't read those original books,
be sure to check them out now.
Dave Filoni. Jon Favreau.
Like I said, changing a lot of plot
elements and characters from then,
but it's all coming from that trilogy.
if you read it, a lot of what
you're seeing on all the shows right now
will seem very familiar.
For instance, on the Bad Batch series
they did Mountaintops.
That's the big plot
element is part of the whole
Luke cloning plot from the Thrawn trilogy.
But in the live action stuff,
they gave a Luke cloning plot to Grogu
who that's what
all the Grogu moff Gideon force
sensitive clone stuff ended up being.
so as part of all that stuff,
Mara Jade has just
been one of the biggest question marks
everybody's had.
Dave Filoni also just recently confirmed
how much of that Thrawn storyline
that they were recognizing
for the upcoming stuff.
know, you need a conflict.
And I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things that were written
over the years in various
expanding universe projects,
trying
not just to look at what John and I did,
but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time
period is a guide, I think, for,
you know, generations of Star Wars fans
before the era of, you know, episode 79
that was what we saw as we turn
to the Jedi era, when you're talking about
story and characters,
I think in the expanding universe.
So there is a treasure of things to
to draw from,
not just within our own series,
but in the bigger galaxy.
but here's the thing.
I've seen some of you in the comments
actually figured this out already.
Dave Filoni has already made Shin Hati
the new version of Mara
Jade in the live action.
So he's basically
given all of her story arc to shin hati
So that's why they're probably
not actually going to do a character
that's called Mara.
Jade They're just going to do Shin Hati,
give her storyline to her.
for those of you
who have not read the Thrawn trilogy
or any of the expanded Universe stories
featuring the Margie character,
she was way more than just Luke
Skywalker's wife.
She was a huge character.
she was a Jedi
born during the rise of the Empire
after Revenge of the Sith,
about the same age as Luke Skywalker.
who the Emperor found in
made his apprentice after Darth Vader
and trained her
separately from the inquisitors.
The inquisitors were like
his blunt instrument
that he used to wipe out
the rest of the Jedi.
Any other force
sensitive people that they could find.
Mora Jade was meant to be more of a Sith
assassin, but at the time she was created,
the Star Wars People behind the scenes
hadn't
really figured out what they were doing
with the backstory of the Sith.
That didn't happen till the mid-nineties.
She was created in the early nineties.
The actual term Sith was created
during the original trilogy
because Darth Vader was described
in the original scripts as a Dark
Lord of the Sith.
a lot of the expanded Golden age
of the Sith self
that didn't come to like the mid nineties.
so when she was introduced
instead of calling her
just the next Sith apprentice
to the emperor,
she was just called the Emperor's hand
in like a dark Jedi.
but basically that's what she was.
She was the Emperor's next Padawan
She was meant to be almost as powerful
as Luke Skywalker.
Like, early on, she was able to match him,
but eventually he grew a little bit
more powerful.
wound up happening
is that the Emperor sends her to Job
as powerless to kill Luke Skywalker.
During the events of Return of the Jedi,
this sort of right corner into that story,
she fails.
And then after the Emperor's killed
by Darth Vader, she actually mistakenly
blamed him for the Emperor's death
and tries to kill him.
for example, she also didn't know that
Anthony and Skywalker was Darth Vader.
after return of the Jedi, though
she goes on the run, becomes a mercenary
and then finds a bounty on Luke Skywalker.
Posted by Thrawn because this is
in the middle of the Thrawn trilogy
Thrawn basically puts a hit out
on Luke Skywalker because he senses
that he could be a big problem
and throw his plans off the rails.
they actually had their first real meeting
on the home planet of the Salem area
where she captured him.
Those are the creatures that block
the force that you see in Theron's office
here in Star Wars Rebels
maybe we'll eventually see
live action versions of that,
like if he has the carvings
of them in his office,
that means that they exist
in the star Wars universe
because everything from Star Wars
rebels is canon in the Sokka is kind of
like Star Wars rebels Season five.
wound up happening between Mara Jade
and Luke Skywalker though is it slowly
he won her over.
She started to relent a little bit
and eventually turned good.
They started their relationship,
they got married,
and she started helping him at his Jedi
Academy.
their son was named Ben
Skywalker after Obi-Wan Kenobi,
but they gave that name to Ben Solo
during the sequel trilogy.
So like a lot of the plot
elements, characters from the Thrawn
trilogy have been re canonized,
but they sort of changed things
and given them to other characters
and sort of spread this stuff around.
Now, Dave Filoni has done that
with Marge's storyline, giving it to
she in Haiti
during that original Thrawn storyline,
Thrawn created a clone of a Jedi master
to give him access to the force
in enhancing the strength of his armies
on a soldier.
They've changed that to the Knights
sisters in their zombie army.
They're calling those the night troopers
and also the Baylan Skoll character.
this sort of split
those plot elements that character
into a couple of different ideas.
Bill in school
is just like the other half of that,
the Dark Jedi who is briefly serving
Thrawn In on the series.
She in Haiti is the Dark Jedi apprentice
serving him.
But she's also meant to take a lot of that
original Mera jade arg The Dark Jedi
who starts out
as an antagonist to all the characters
and eventually turns good? no.
Even if they do
like five seasons of Ahsoka,
I don't think they're going to get her
married
to Luke Skywalker or anything like that.
But heading into a season two,
the Thrawn movie, they started to slowly
put her on that redemption
arc that Mara Jade got.
that was, what their reason Fight scene.
Her last moments with Balan
School were all about.
He planned to stay behind on the parity
a planet in that other galaxy to pursue
that secret power quote unquote, that
hopefully we'll learn about in the finale
and wanted her
to return to the main galaxy with Thrawn.
Then Ahsoka offered her hand to her
as a way of showing
that she wanted to help her, offer her
a way out if she wanted to leave Thrawn.
But it's way too early for that to happen,
so they're just
teasing the beginning of that.
if things wind up working out
with the first Thrawn movie,
I think they plan on doing
the full trilogy of Thrawn movies
in a couple of seasons of the saga
between those they've already started
to circle season two, but we'll see
when it comes to multiple Thrawn movies
Based on experience.
The way Jon Favreau Dave Filoni
pays things out over the different series.
merrily there is that she wouldn't
turn good until either the second movie
if they do wind up doing a trilogy
and we're saying
they're adapting
the Thrawn trilogy movies,
it would be like their version
of Dark Force Rising,
which in a serious case
would be a reference to the Knights sister
Zombie Army.
in at least right now.
The way things are going,
the only way Ahsoka Season two comes out
before the Thrawn movie
is that they start filming it next year
right
after they finish the Mandalorian Season
four.
otherwise season two wouldn't come out
until after the first Thrawn movie.
So the pacing of all this stuff,
like when stuff actually happens,
could change a little bit
depending on how quickly they move.
now. As for Luke Skywalker,
like the other side of this margin
equation, Ahsoka told him that
they probably see each other again.
to make a Lord of the Rings reference.
If this were like
the Fellowship of the Ring,
so to speak, the Fellowship
of the hyperspace ring,
imagine like the first half of that movie
where the fellowship
actually comes together.
That's basically
been all of this focus season one,
just like the first half of that movie.
all the episodes pretty much dedicated
to just getting her
to that other galaxy and finding out
what happened with Thrawn this whole time.
What happened with Ezra
Bridger season two in the Thrawn movie
would be like everything that happens
after Thrawn comes back to the main galaxy
when stuff really starts to get going.
that's when you start to hear
about the other major characters like Luke
Skywalker.
Grogu the Mandalorian,
the other Mandalorians getting involved.
right now, everything that's happening on
Ahsoka is taking place directly
after the Mandalorian Season three,
which took place after the book of Boba
Fett, meaning that Luke Skywalker
has just continued right now
while this is happening,
setting up his new Jedi Academy,
looking for people to train
most of his energy is dedicated to that,
which is why he hasn't gotten involved
in the larger
things going on in the galaxy.
also the way they portrayed
The New Republic.
Right now, they kind of suck.
So it sounds like Luke Skywalker
would try to ignore all of that
just to avoid the headache of dealing with
all those crazy New Republic senators.
in Since the end of the Mandalorian Season
three, Mando has just been training
Grogu who how to become a bounty hunter
and become a Mandalorian.
They might have heard more whispers
about what the Shadow Council is doing
since the end of season three,
But he largely didn't get too involved
with the Shadow Council
in the Thrawn stuff
at the end of the Mandalorian Season
three.
that was more of a teaser for Ahsoka
than it was for The Mandalorian.
Characters.
Like most of the Mandalorian characters
didn't hear Moff Gideon
talking about Thrawn.
He was only talking about his force
sensitive clones
and taking over the galaxy himself.
So it's very likely that the Mandalorians,
including Mando and Grogu,
who don't even know about Thrawn yet.
I think they're saving that
for the Mandalorian Season four,
because by that time Thrawn
will have come back to the main galaxy.
You start to see the shadow Council
converging, bringing their army to bear
until the end of that series
when the Thrawn movie starts to pick up.
there'll be a lot of cliffhangers for this
and the Ahsoka finale.
Don't expect them to answer
all these questions.
my. Actual finale video will post
in a couple of days after they release it,
but after that I'll start doing more
Season 2 videos, More Mandalorian Season
4 videos explaining what's going on.
Next.
click here for that Ahsoka
Episode 8 finale video and the link.
As soon as I post that and click here
for my trailers for all the other upcoming
Star Wars series like Star Wars
Acolyte, The Skeleton Crew Trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!